what's up everyone i'm back for another
video um
currently wallowing a lot of self-pity
and anger
after having two frozen yogurts two
slices of pizza and wings last night and
thus killing my diet probably for the
next week um that's tough uh okay let's
talk about certificate transparency this
is actually going to be a long one and
i'm still kind of hungover so let's see
if i get through it okay so certificate
transparency what is that well basically
in the past i've talked about tcp and
udp which are both network protocols to
ensure that you know bytes kind of get
delivered over the internet however they
don't really ensure that you know
they're encrypted in any sort of way or
that if they were to get into the wrong
hands that the that person wouldn't be
able to read them so instead what we're
going to talk about in this video is
something called certificate
transparency which is used in a separate
protocol called https which is basically
built on top of http and uses a ssl or
tls layer of security in order to ensure
that bytes sent to you know the party
that shouldn't be having them can't go
ahead and just interpret them so how
does this work
well just to firstly describe the actual
problem that we're trying to fix we have
man in the middle attacks so man the
middle attacks are basically when you
have your user and your typical web
server and the user thinks they're
actually going and sending requests to
the web server but somehow the
perpetrator is basically disguised their
ip in a way such that the user is
actually communicating with them and so
if they're sending things like passwords
or valuable information like location
data the man in the middle can go ahead
and just read that and so the only way
to kind of avoid this happening is not
necessarily not dealing with man in the
middle but just you know being able to
actually encrypt your data such that if
some malicious third party were to
actually get it they wouldn't be able to
understand it
okay so in order to do this we actually
use rsa encryption so this is also known
as public key encryption
basically any server that you want to
communicate with has something called a
public key and a private key and that
public key it doesn't really matter who
has it but the point is you can use this
public key to go ahead and encrypt
whatever data you want and then and then
go ahead and send that data over the
network and only the person with the
private key can go ahead and decrypt it
to actually read it so this is actually
where
you know the server would use their
private key and they're the only one
that has it because they haven't
conveyed that over the network and that
way even if the data were to fall into
the wrong hands it would be encrypted
which is great
that being said
it comes at the caveat that the client
has to make sure they're using the right
public key they want to be sure that
they're using it from the server and not
necessarily from the actual man in the
middle and get tricked so how can they
ensure
that they're going ahead and using the
right encryption well the server issues
something called a certificate
so basically a certificate goes ahead
and says that the server is who they say
they are and the certificate gets
registered with some centralized
certificate authority and the
certificate provides things like the
owner of the server its ip address it's
public key because you're going to use
that public key to encrypt things and
also this concept of a digital signature
which is what the browser is ultimately
going to use to determine that the
certificate is valid so how can you go
ahead and use that digital signature
well basically you do the following
the browser connects to the server the
server goes ahead and sends that
certificate which i just mentioned in
the last slide
then the browser is going to verify it
via the digital signature which i'll
describe in a second and then upon
completion all the server is going to do
is basically say here's a random key
um i'm going to encrypt it using the
server's public key and if the server
can go ahead and respond using its
private key
you know because it was able to
successfully decrypt the data then i
know that you are actually the proper
server however that being said all of
this doesn't necessarily prove that the
certificate itself is not bogus it just
proves that once you have a certificate
the server can quickly verify that it is
actually the one who you know the
certificate corresponds to
um basically that digital signature that
i mentioned prior which is issued by a
certificate authority can be verified
because the certificate authority also
has its own public and private key pair
and in this case it's going to use its
local private key to encrypt the
certificate send out its public key and
you know the browser basically has a
list of public keys for trusted
certificate authorities and then that
way the browser can go ahead and just
decrypt that um
you know certificate
using that digital signature and if the
decryption matches the actual
certificate itself then you know you're
good to go and that it is a valid
certificate from that certificate
authority however like i said there are
a few issues here mainly being that
how can we trust the certificate
authority what if the certificate
authority was actually to get hacked
so like i said the malicious actor could
start just issuing itself certificates
and basically say oh i'm netflix.com you
know you can communicate with me give me
your credit card information give me
your passwords etc etc etc so you know
even though you might be able to verify
that hey this certificate here is from a
certificate authority that i trust um
and hey
you know now once i have this
certificate i can actually go ahead and
send encrypted information back and
forth with the server if you can't trust
the ca what you need is an additional
step called certificate transparency
certificate transparency basically does
the following it goes ahead and publicly
broadcasts all issued certificates by
every single certificate authority so
that bogus certificates can basically be
flushed out and it can't be done
instantly but you can basically you know
have a process where you can relatively
quickly notice these bogus certificates
and you know revoke them so this has
basically three main components
certificate logs monitors and auditors
and i'm going to go into all three of
those now
so basically certificate logs can add
all the certificates to append only logs
sorry certificate authorities would do
that and then each of those can be
queried by an auditor which is just a
program running on the web browser to
ensure that a certificate is in it and
we'll go ahead and talk about how that
works in a second
and then additionally each website so
basically each um you know if i'm
netflix and i have my application
servers in addition to running these
servers i'm running a set of programs
also known as monitors which are going
to basically be pulling from all of
these certificate logs and making sure
that no one is issuing bogus
certificates under my name if they are i
would go ahead and revoke them
however this isn't perfect because again
how can we make sure that we can
actually trust the log the log could
perhaps temporarily show
a browser a bogus entry and then delete
it from the log if we can't trust you
know the server maintaining the log or
additionally the log can actually have
basically a fork and you can think of
this like a git fork where
you have two different paths of the log
and one path is being shown to the
browser and the other path is being
shown to the auditor so the auditor
never sees the bad path being shown to
the browser and revokes that bad
certificate and the browser thinks it's
you know dealing with totally fine
certificate log thus sending all of this
sensitive data and boom now someone else
is stealing it so you know how can we
actually go ahead and make sure that's
not happening
well this is actually really cool we're
going to be using merkle trees and doing
cryptographic proofs so basically we're
going to first generate a merkle tree
from the log itself and get the root
hash of it and then so basically to
ensure that a given element is in the
merkle tree because you know like i said
the browser's job is to basically say oh
is this element here in the actual log
itself and you want to be able to trust
that
basically what you would do
is you would go ahead and use that
element and go ahead and basically use
a bunch of other elements within the
merkle tree to basically see if you can
recreate that root hash and if you can
you've cryptographically proved that
that element is actually in the log
itself and i'll demonstrate this process
on the next slide so it makes a little
bit more sense and it's really hard to
fake this because you know faking it
insinuates that you are able to find
some combination of elements that
perfectly hashes to the root that
basically involves your fake certificate
which is really hard to do so people
basically just assume that this
cryptographic proof is pretty solid and
set in stone so i'll show what i mean
now
so imagine we have these four
certificates and they're in a merkle
tree and feel free to go back to my
merkle tree video if you kind of forget
what these are but basically it's just a
tree of hashes and each higher parent
node is a hash of the two children nodes
so we have c1 c2 c3 c4 what if we want
to ensure that c1 is actually in the
tree
so what we would go ahead and do is
basically say okay we have c1 and then
you know in order to go ahead and
optimize this proof and not have to
reconstruct the entire merkle tree what
you do is you only gather all the hashes
from opposite branches so in this case
that would be 45 ty and 99 j7 so that
way we only have log n hashes this
greatly
increases the time it takes to do this
proof
and what we would then basically do
is reconstruct the merkle tree root from
those hashes and that way we can check
if you know if the roots are equal then
we're good to go so basically we're
saying we take c1 um you know
concatenate it with 45 ty which is the
opposite branch take the hash of that
which should be 143c concatenate that
with 99j7 take the hash of that and if
it's equal to tyg4 then we know that
c1 is in fact in the lock
however how can we even be sure that we
received a correct
root hash in the first place um you know
it might be the case that um you know
the certificate log server couldn't be
trusted and the log again might be able
to show um two forks because it might
show the browser one and then
the monitor a different version so again
we have a potential problem here
well again we're still using merkle
trees to make our proof
so basically the way the only way to
really get around this and this is
unfortunately only something that you
know kind of has this eventual
consistency aspect to it where
it's possible the browser can get
tricked for a little bit and then it'll
eventually realize that it's being
tricked
is that basically we have this gossip
pool
and this gossip pool
is a bunch of browsers and a bunch of
monitors throwing into one centralized
area basically all of these root hashes
that they've seen
from um
from all of the logs that they've been
reading and so as a result of that you
know if a browser throws in some sort of
hash
and
a monitor throws in its own hash of
basically the two logs that i've seen
you can actually use merkle trees and do
a similar proof to how we did before to
show that one log is not actually either
the same or a prefix of the other and if
we know that one log is not a prefix of
the other from the same
log server then clearly that log server
is forked and it is a bad actor um
additionally browsers will always make
sure to read from the same fork so that
you know the log server can't just like
pull a fast one on them and go ahead and
switch it to another fork and then the
the browser is like wait a second did i
just give up sensitive data
so
as long as the browser is reading from
the same fork which it can continue to
do by using miracle trees and kind of
checking these uh this like prefix
consistency
then the browser will eventually realize
due to this gossip pool that it was
reading from a bad fork and ultimately
that will solve the problem so
even though
these proofs are really useful for
pointing out when a browser has been
duped obviously they're not perfect
because it doesn't prevent
you know a bad log from basically you
know stealing information from a browser
for a little bit of time that being said
the kind of ideal thing is that all of
these monitors are running so frequently
that they can be caught relatively
quickly and as a result either not too
much data will be leaked or you know
nothing important will
so
it's kind of important to note that
certificate transparency isn't perfect
but it is a very interesting system that
generally speaking kind of just shows
off the general approach that a lot of
people have taken to kind of building
these decentralized networks and in a
subsequent video which i look forward to
making where we talk about you know
cryptocurrency and blockchain which kind
of also relies on this for consistency
and the concept of using merkle trees um
we're going to see that basically this
concept is something that repeats a lot
so i hope this video was useful guys and
then it makes sense i know i kind of
went through a lot and not a lot of time
but um you know i'll post some
recommended reading and viewing as i
tend to do in the description and you
know if anything wasn't clear feel free
to take a look at those